what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
really
but then
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
let's go
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we can wake them up with a
wave of passion they've never felt
before
Magic
the real question is why do you love her
no one's believed in me like your mom
has
so what's the show about it's the same
or will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick Love and Money
[Music]
the real question is why does she feel
like she has to choose it sounds to me
she just needs to let go
and some good
[Music]
maybe that as well
[Music]
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants there's
[Music]
this right is your arrest her what's
your name Kim
let you out for the warning right
[Music]